avez pu suivre avec nous donc les
derniers développements sur le terrain
pour les analyser notre expert des
questions militaires guillaume las
conchas nous a rejoint en plateau de
guillaume bonjour on voulait revenir
avec vous d'abord guillaume on l'a vu au
début de notre édition sur marioupol on
dit que c'est un verrou stratégique
cette ville sa prise par les russes donc
ça permettrait de faire une jonction
avec d'autres forces venues venue de là
ce serait un changement majeur dans
cette guerre on l'imaginait alors ce
serait tout à fait un changement assez
important pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que outre sa position de deux
verrous qui interdit pour l'instant la
jonction des unités qui descendent du
dombass et de celles qui remonte
d'ukraine pour créer véritablement cette
continuité territoriale est bloquée ou
contrôler la totalité de la mer d'azov
marioupol c'est aussi une ville
importante c'est une ville industrielle
et c'est un port en eau profonde c'est à
dire que quelque part c'est une prise de
guerre assez importante assez
conséquente et cela finalement peu donné
à poutine l'idée que finalement ces buts
de guerre peuvent déjà être atteint même
si au regard des ambitions qu'il affiche
ou que l'on peut observer avec la
totalité de des forces qu'il engage
actuellement en ukraine ce n'est qu'une
partie sans doute de ce qu'ils espèrent
puisque bien évidemment on observe à
côté de ça la multiplication des sièges
de grandes villes vous venez juste de
montrer ce qui est en train de se passer
à kiev mais on peut citer ce qui se
passe at cherniff on peut penser aussi à
ce qui se passe à kharkiv est bien
évidemment pas l'oublier ce qui se passe
aussi sur le front du donbass guillaume
un mois avec vous sur les combats à kiev
le siège de la capitale apparaît de plus
en plus apparaît plus en plus proche
d'heure en heure mais les forces russes
notamment évoqué ces deux longs colonne
de blindés qui descendait du nord vers
vers kiev semble être ralenti par une
forte résistance ukrainienne est ce que
leur progression va être là aussi
ralentis ou est-ce que comment comment
ça peut se dérouler ce qu'on imagine que
les forces russes peuvent rencontrer une
féroce résistance on imagine on observe
en fait depuis
à peu près maintenant trois ou quatre
jours cette colonne qui est très
fortement ralenti alors allait ralentir
mon avis pour trois raisons d'abord une
question de pure logistique c'est à dire
que vous avez sur un seul axe
énormément de véhicules qui sont
littéralement en train de se de se
toucher et dans un corridor qui est
relativement peu large ce qui est
interdit en fait une manoeuvre
d'ensemble et donc de pouvoir déboucher
ensuite quand je dis débouchés débouchés
ou et sur quoi bas il faut un terrain
libre sauf que c'est peut-être pas
forcément de le le bon moment la
question qui va se poser un moment ou un
autre c'est celle de ce qu'on appelle la
saison des boules à raspoutine ça c'est
à dire le dégel qui verrait en fait
l'interdiction totale même pour des
véhicules chenillés de passer par des
chants des plaines etc et puis la
troisième raison c'est tout simplement
une raisons logistiques c'est à dire que
les élongations logistique font que les
russes tombent manifestement assez
régulièrement en panne d'essence qu'ils
ont un problème à ravitailler cette
longue colonne parce que tout simplement
les plots logistique sont loin en
arrière et que la logistique russe
traditionnellement dépend beaucoup des
noeuds ferroviaires alors ce n'est pas
tellement le cas pour cette colonne
l'acquis et qui s'avance vers vers kiev
qui elle est dépendante plutôt de la
route mais on peut observer par exemple
que du côté de soumis du côté de kharkiv
là où les élongations logistique sont
appuyés sur le rail par exemple la prise
de la ville de cosne au top et là-dessus
essentiels eh bien on peut observer que
les avancées notamment des blindés
russes et est un petit peu plus facilité
donc il ya une conjonction entre bien
sûr les besoins des chars les besoins
des véhicules blindés et puis bien
évidemment la possibilité de leur
fournir leur carburant
dernière question d'un mot également
avec vous guillaume sur cette no fly
zone on l'est on l'a écouté on a écouté
président céline ski juste avant votre
intervention qui donc d'une certaine
manière reproché aux occidentaux à
l'otan de ne pas mettre en place cette
zone d'exclusion aérienne au dessus de
au dessus de l'ukraine dans les faits
c'est quasiment un faisable à moins
d'une déclaration cessera reviendrait à
une déclaration de guerre entre l'otan
et la russie en fait c'est ce que dit
effectivement poutine mais il faut bien
en fait au delà de ça reprendre ce qui a
été dit de manière très claire par
l'otan hier l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord est une alliance
défensive se préciser dans ce tout dans
tout le traité est une zone d'exclusion
aérienne c'est véritablement en fait une
mesure qui paraît défensive
effectivement mais qui par sa mise en
oeuvre fondamentalement exigerait de
déplacer des avions des aéronefs donc au
dessus de l'ukraine où leur mission
serait littéralement d'intercepter et
peut-être même d'abattre des avions
russes et dans ces cas là effectivement
l' escalade ne manquerait pas
d'intervenir et on se retrouverait
véritablement une affronte dans un
affrontement direct avec les
conséquences que l'on peut imaginer en
revanche que l'on peut dire c'est que
l'alliance met en place toutes les
mesures pour protéger le territoire des
alliés des pays baltes à la pologne
jusqu'à la roumanie où on a vu les
militaires français se déployer et bien
là on voit justement qu'en revanche la
posture et est beaucoup plus net
beaucoup plus affiché est beaucoup plus
défensive mais avec la capacité cette
fois de protéger chaque centimètre carré
de l'alliance merci beaucoup à guillaume
menace khanjar à ce spécialiste des
questions militaires pour votre analyse